hey video hey Brennan you boy Davey from
Chilliwack British Columbia gang rubber
got a quick debate club question well
Theo considering you're currently
getting into the combat sports and
Brendon you're a form of fight yourself
I want to know who do you guys prefer
Bruce Buffer
or Michael buffer both phenomenal voices
but are you more of a desk get ready to
rhumble type of guy or it's time guys I
love the podcast really appreciate what
you do and love the both year the Rat
King and big brown vo wish I could've
see you in Vancouver but sadly can't
make it there but keep killing it boys I
love you Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz all
right gang bro shout out to voz
shoutouts in Canada the new America yeah
um with Bruce Buffer Michael buffer the
same guy did you know that this exact
same guy know that you know they grew up
they didn't know each other we're gonna
meet - they're like in their
mid-twenties and they are brothers yes
they're brothers here's the thing about
Michael buffer he went Oh Bruce you had
to do all this work from from hailing
from Denver Colorado 14 and 4 you know
number two heavyweight in the world
Brendan and uh he goes on and on and
then the 316 blows his [ __ ] out the
sweating Murray has a suit on
your boy Michaels goes oh seven million
thank you thank you I'm out so Michael
got the better business deal Michael
Mike Michael might be the smarter one
gets paid more and where it's way less
but does Michael still work or Bruce
still works both of them work later God
just see the other day on one of the
fights probably Bruce if you watched the
UFC feel he's the only guy that's why
some guys all of them yeah so he has
Bruce or Michael Michael looks like he
may be no I had a little bit more cloud
he gets a little bit more posse yeah ooh
boy Michael's been in movies he does
those hugh debate if he only does the
other thing about Michael he's a little
bougie he only does the biggest boxing
matches oh he does I feel like Oh bro
will you do this what's on the SPN now
see I want somebody uh then I go with
the other one then I want that guy
that's probably got a black and milds in
his pocket here's the thing about Bruce
Buffer that people are now that my
[ __ ] surface ass off getting a lot of
street fight also do the splits on you
on a dime
really oh yeah also and he'll also go to
Saudi Arabia who go to Taiwan China
doesn't care but doesn't want someone
else coming in on his [ __ ] oh wow
never guy named Jo Martinez but it's
very rare you see him because Bruce is
like Niall no yeah but also Jo Martinez
man he also brings a lot of [ __ ]
violencia knife from my cousin on me
deal it's blood life so stick the script
Joe please he brought a bull into the
ring one time and it's let her run
around for like this I was like oh dude
so everything with Canelo I'm gonna go
with the guy that still has blood in his
body if you can see the images on uh on
the dad once-thriving here's the other
thing about Bruce to man is he he just
he's just such a beast man he's such a
character
I caught him when I first moved out here
I got him I walked into Gold's Gym and I
in front of I'm not walking in right and
I'm like right and I hear loudest [ __ ]
like it's a real UFC fight Brendan the
high bridge in front the whole gym like
oh [ __ ] what's up man I keep going and I
see see he's gonna kill me but he is the
to cable you know like the cable Rose he
has those and he has a UFC shirt on UFC
shorts you want yeah and he's doing a
360 he's doing trying to do the 360 he
has just got to get that core power man
so when I explode explode so everyone's
like others Bruce Buffer doing the 360
serious about his gig dude what's the
360 is it the the Bruce Buffer
is the 180th it's the three so it's a
twenty goes and jumps you know you got
yes he blew out his knee doing it he did
he's doing he's doing karaoke and blue
that's me haha 36 in the breeze bar 5060
already way more interesting than
Michael dude Michael keeps it Michael's
just he's too rich yeah no Mike Michael
you rich rich oh here's a thing now I'm
just educating your ass here's the other
thing
Bruce is Michael's manager no yeah Bruce
is Michael's manager yeah huh
interesting any other brain Buster's
most fan bases all easily do one seven
times seven yeah Britain shorts out
you're right Brendan gets back in his
skill crane and [ __ ] crank set of
external crane we still found it funny
the first time
yeah especially this fan be evil like
Bruce Michaels does he do he do you ring
them up so much there wait Michael utter
ripple now Mike Michael another love but
imagine Michael at a library or
something let's get ready to read yeah
those kids are fired up do jump Jo
Martinez is the one we should probably
hired hitting that [ __ ] Spanish
flavor that Mexican flavor
possibly
back off my broccolini
get your life together I'm not touching